welcome to the r studio enterprise
community meetup
i think it was a little delayed here so
let me start over again hi friends thank
you so much for joining us today
welcome to the rstudio enterprise
community meetup i'm rachel calling in
from a rainy boston today
if you just joined now feel free to say
hi through the chat window and maybe
we're calling in from
if this is your first time joining one
of these sessions we do have them every
tuesday at noon eastern time
and so i'll share a calendar of all the
upcoming events in the chat in just a
second here where you can add whole
calendar or individual events to your
own calendar too
this is a friendly and open meetup
environment for teams to share different
use cases with each other and teach
lessons learned
together we're all dedicated to making
this an inclusive and open environment
for everyone no matter your experience
your industry or background
during the event you can also ask
questions on the platform that you are
watching from
you're also able to ask anonymous
questions as well
through
rstd dot io slash meetup questions which
i'll put on the screen here in just a
second too
but with all of that
welcome thank you so much for joining us
i would love to pull
ryan up here on stage
and let me
handle my little side panel here
hi hi and thanks so much for joining us
ryan lee's veterans affairs quantitative
approach to improving employee
engagement primarily through feedback
and related outcome data
thank you ryan for for sharing your
experience
absolutely thank you rachel and thank
you all for the time
so i'll talk about how we use shinee and
rstudio connect
at the department of veterans affairs
for our executive dashboard project
so
as you probably know
va's mission which of course i'm here to
talk about our work specifically not not
via more broadly uh va's mission is to
provide health care
and benefits and burial services for us
veterans
and the mission of my office of ncod
is to improve employee engagement in va
so that those services can be provided
most effectively
we do that
in the way that's most relevant here
through enterprise survey and data
science services
so some context for that work is that va
is quite large as you may know
400 000 plus employees from
manila to san juan to maine
every kind of occupation you can think
of
hundreds of hospitals and clinics and
benefits offices and cemeteries
so in contrast to that my office is
quite small
our head count is about 50.
so on one hand that's really exciting
because we can
have a very outsized impact and work in
a very high leveraged way
but it also means we have to punch way
above our weight class to have the kind
of impact that we need to have
so some of the tools and processes i can
talk about today
are what help us do that
so just a little bit of info about the
data that go into the application i'll
show you and then we'll of course jump
into the actual app
the primary data source from
surveys that we use is something called
the all employee survey
and every year va administers the aes to
every employee
very comprehensive it covers everything
from engagement to burnout to
psychological safety patient safety
specific modules for specific
occupations so there's between 70 and
120 questions depending on what you do
and it's our primary data source for
organizational health and it's also
one of the most important maybe in some
ways the most important feedback
mechanism that va has
for hearing about how we can provide
better services to veterans
it gets a great response rate so we have
representative high quality data about
70 response rate this year
people feel like they can be honest
because it's anonymous
and
the data go lots of places um into
executives performance plans and get
reported in important ways
but from ncod's perspective the most
important purpose of the data is for
work group level improvement
so work group is just a group of five or
10 or 15 people who work together on a
day-to-day basis
so for that improvement to happen first
of all of course work groups need to
have their data and be able to discuss
it and see what it's telling them and
strategize about how to improve their
day-to-day work life
but for purposes today at the executive
level of course executives need
to know what's going on
basically
they need to know where their hot spots
things to watch out for
any trends that may be concerning or
noteworthy
and so the app and the briefing process
that
we use helps get executives that level
of data uh they need in a in a quick way
and then also in a way that's very
durable and that they can use as a
reference
so we we brief every executive team in
va which is about 300 teams
um
2 000 probably closer to 2 500
individuals so for example
at a hospital the executive team would
be
the director
um a few service chiefs and maybe a few
other uh people too so the top four five
six seven people at every site
and we briefed them directly from the
dashboard that i'll show you in just a
second so
we used to use giant powerpoints and big
excel files and
those were great as references but as
you can imagine not terribly compelling
when you have the kind of data we have
at the scale that we have it so the
dashboard has been a huge improvement
for us
just a few a few final points about the
app itself
flat csv files are our data source so no
fancy apis or
databases
and the displays are also pretty simple
as you'll see we mostly use bar charts
line graphs and tables and i note this
here because
if you're like me you see some of the
really sophisticated and cool apps that
other people make that do have bring in
lots of other data sources and have lots
of cool plugins and so on
and it's easy for at least for me to
think that you have to do that kind of
stuff for it to be useful so for what
it's worth we've gotten a lot of mileage
out of uh
pretty simple uh back ends
um
the other thing you'll see that we put a
lot of work into is for the interface to
look relatively coherent hopefully and
for it to be
predictable
because with the audience we have it's
just not tenable to expect you know 2500
executives to learn some
idiosyncratic interface or deal with
fiddly
ui issues so it needs to be very
predictable very polished and also
pretty responsive because these
briefings last for 60 minutes and
that's a lot of time but also it's it's
not um so even if we had a few minutes
of cumulative lag waiting for things to
update or to calculate
that's a decent percentage of our total
time so
those are some considerations that we
we've had to deal with while building
this application
uh i'll try to pause for questions
periodically but feel free to interrupt
uh with any questions or
points of elaboration you'd like me to
make
so with that i will
change screens uh hopefully
i'm just gonna say i'll i'll pop in here
when there are some questions too but
just wanted to remind everyone that you
can ask either on
linkedin if you're watching there or on
youtube live
also there's the slido link for
anonymous questions too
and so one of the considerations that if
you do this at scale you'll run into is
bandwidth so we have
a relatively large uh back-end server
but when you have
hundreds of people coming at the same
time to it it's going to sometimes be
slow so hopefully hopefully we get a
pretty good
response now because actually the
briefings are going on right now so i
came from one this morning i've got one
this afternoon so there's a lot of
traffic on this platform right now
so the first thing you see when you go
to the link that we give to all
executives and i'll just make it uh full
screen
um
va's numbers come up by default so one
of the good things about doing it in
this way
is that it's really easy to be very
transparent with all the data
that we have because anybody in va can
pick data for any group in va
so there's no kind of
compartmentalizing the information
everything is fully available for anyone
to see
the other thing that that makes it very
easy to do is to go into deep dives on
specific
groups that may be of interest during a
particular briefing
so for briefing the
uh one of the under secretaries for
example who are over lots of different
facilities
and they have a question about a
specific facility we can go right to
that facility in this input and
everything else updates with that
facility's data so it's a great way to
be responsive in real time versus having
to take questions and then come back
with additional reports
so i'll go to our
our demo
page which has um
fictitious data so it's representative
of what a facility would see but the
numbers are not
um not real
uh so as i go through this i'll show you
what what we have and i'll try to focus
more on the app itself than the data
points uh which is kind of backwards
from how the briefings would go of
course but i'm happy to talk about any
of it so feel free to break in with
questions on
uh the app itself or the data
so
the first thing you may notice is that
it doesn't look like the standard shiny
app that you get by default
um
it's a bootstrap page running bootstrap
5 with the bslib package
so that gives us a good bit of
flexibility because then we can use
bootstrap's native row column layout
to get exactly what we want
it's also
so you you'll notice the picture for
example in the top right
uh so for every facility we find a story
about that facility from from
uh that that's been published by that
facility itself
that talks about some service that's
been provided or some efforts that have
been undertaken
that are what the data we have tried to
promote
so in the case here this is the picture
from the chicago va
and a lot of va's do this and it's
really cool they partner with local
community um
service organizations veterans
organizations and so on
and they'll do things like uh drive
through baby showers
so if you're a veteran and your family
just had a baby and you need some help
you can show up and drive through
basically a big tunnel where they
load you up with everything that you
need in your car
um and if you haven't seen that kind of
the kind of impact that that kind of
service and work can have it's really
really effective
um
so
we try to tie in what's actually going
on on the ground to the data we have
just to build a connection
uh there's a story that's linked behind
the picture and i'll not click on it now
just to save the back and forth but
the actual stories are linked here as
well
there's a
a video that we put behind a um it's an
embedded youtube video it's in an iframe
and it just sets its own for why we do
the survey in the first place it's not
really about
tracking a bunch of numbers it's about
changing how people
experience their their day-to-day work
at va
and then throughout you'll also see
a red yellow green color heuristic by
default to indicate when a score is
good or okay or not so great
of course some people can't see that so
it's easy to change to an alternate
palette or to pick a custom palette that
anybody can see
the trick with something like this that
i learned the hard way is you want to
bring in the color scheme
as late in the reactive chain as you can
so that if someone changes the color
scheme you're not re-firing all the
reactives
that would do data manipulations that
don't need to be redone you want to just
reskin the grafts basically
and it's
tedious to do that after you do it the
other way so you want to make sure to do
that early on
so the first thing we show people are
some key numbers that correspond to
important things that va leaders care
about
the response rate obviously is important
because you need to know how
representative your data are
data sharing and data use refer to the
extent that people at that organization
say they've seen their data and that
it's been used to
improve their day-to-day work life
so if you
do some
back of the envelope math
the va score on this is 42 so we're
talking you know about
uh 200 000 people
uh who say that this
specific survey has made improvements in
how that has led to improvements and how
they are able to uh to provide their
service to veterans
everything from uh
getting pharmacy medications turned
around quicker from prescription to
administration
lots of employee wellness activities
lots of governance to do with nursing
groups so the the places that groups go
once they start talking about how they
feel about their work and what can be
done better
are usually really really impactful and
that's why we try to push the data down
as low in the organization as we can
best places to work is an overall job
satisfaction measure so each of these
tiles have a color that corresponds to
the valence of that score
and they also have a click of it
that
shows a drill down in a few different
ways
and this is one of the things we try to
do that's consistent across the
different data displays we have
there's a quick takeaway that you can
get just at a glance and then there's
more that you can get one level down
sometimes two
if you really want to
so it's great for a briefing because you
can kind of read the room and see where
people want to spend their time
so in this case we have scores for the
facility
uh its region
the entire healthcare sector of va and
then up to va overall just for some
context for this year and for last year
uh so everything we show has uh some
comparison data and everything we show
also has the change score since last
year
piers shows how the site stacks up
against other sites in its region
so these are other va facilities in the
same region as boston
so people often want to know
what rank they are how they stack up
this gets those questions out of the way
early on so they can focus on the
within facility data that's usually more
more impactful
direct reports is one level down in the
org chart and i should say to all these
tables and graphs
are sorted by default so there's a
useful
sort based on the scale
so you don't have to kind of orient
yourself to where the high scores are
they
or the low scores they filter
automatically
and that's a small thing but when you
have so much data the the usability gain
you get from that is really important
uh the colors correspond to statistical
testing uh of groups
so green is better than a comparison
group or
improved since last year red of course
is the reverse
and uh here we can look back to 2018 to
get the trajectory
so each of these has that same ability
i'll i'll spare you the details with
going through each one but that's the
that's the ui piece here
uh each of these also has a breakout
that's
that corresponds to the org chart so
response rates chosen by default but
i'll select best places to work
so every organization as i mentioned is
mapped all the way down to the very
small team level 5 10 15 people
so this is a very intuitive display for
people especially for executives because
it matches the scheme of the
organization that they already have
the caller of course corresponds to the
value of the score there's a scale
up here with va
for reference
again these numbers just to reiterate
these numbers are fictitious but
representative of the kind of variance
that you see
so they stop at two levels down by
default just because hospitals are big
places but if you want to see everything
uh then you can uncheck that quick map
toggle and now there's a lot because
again it's a big organization but you
can get a quick visual triage of the
entire organization
so you can imagine as a director as a
service chief
you can really start to see just quickly
where some of the
hotspots and bright spots are within
your organization
the additional layer of detail
here is on
is accessed by clicking on the dot
so if i wanted to click on i'm just
picking a group at random here i can see
a drill down into their specific data
and also a scrambled supervisor email
here
as mapped locally
easy to follow up with people this way
i did see a question i'm trying to watch
the chat but there are lots of questions
i saw a question about the url of the
site uh this is internal to va so nobody
outside va could access it so that's why
there's no url available
i can help uh ask some of the questions
too ryan yeah please okay awesome yeah i
was just popping in there i didn't want
to interrupt the flow though
one of the um
questions that people asked on slido was
i'm new to r in r studio and my employer
would like their data source refresh
daily use in their script
is shiny the recommended method
so we don't do a lot of that honestly uh
because we have
sort of large single efforts versus kind
of continuous incoming data i've seen
really effective use cases for that um
i think it depends a lot on the way the
data are stored and
to the extent that you can access it
through some sort of api or database
thank you
another question that came up earlier
was
is there any concern from i.t regarding
the use of r and shiny
as the government traditionally uses sas
or is this true
um
so
there is concern there is inertia to
overcome
that's been a process
um
you need at least in my experience you
need executive sponsorship to be able to
say
um why the ultimate outcome matters
because
a lot of it departments aren't going to
care about the details of this they care
about security they care about
maintainability
so if you can get somebody at a level
that has sway with other i.t leaders to
make them
care and see the value then you can get
more movement that way
at least in va there's a really detailed
process to go through
to get
approved to be
an app and to be on in our case azure
there's a federal azure space that we're
on
so we have to go through all that review
which is slow but
you do get there eventually
as a follow-up to that i love uh
hugh's comment in the chat he said this
is amazing i work for vha and this app
is so much better than how we used to
get
aes results you might need to help me on
the acronyms here but what has been your
experience with r and va
uh thank you
for the feedback it's been it's been
good
especially for local work so using it on
your desktop is not an issue
it takes an admin to install rstudio but
that's typically not a problem
uh to get on azure and get connect and
then get stood up that way is you know i
mentioned a pretty long process it took
a couple years
um there's a lot of contracting and i t
and
uh
and uh you know related functions that
have to be on the same page
but i think it's doable we we certainly
did it it just did take a long time
can i ask you a follow-up to that if
somebody is listening now and starting
that process of what is something that
you
wish you knew about then or something
that was really helpful to you through
that process
um something that is helpful that i wish
i'd done earlier is do what i suggest
that people do and have an executive
sponsor at a high level that comes in to
clear some of the obstacles
um
there is it's like any bureaucracy i
think there are a lot more people who
can say no than can say yes
so you need to find that person who can
really motivate people to work on this
project on your behalf
thank you
i'll um i'll save some of the other
questions for a little bit later so i'll
let you get back to the talk thank you i
i did see one that's easy to take um
limitations on va vhas azure space
crayon only or github um
haven't run into any limitations yet we
try to study with crayon just for
reliability reasons but
no issues there
great thank you sure
so
uh next we talk about employee
engagement and burnout and we do that in
the same
uh in the same way and with the same
kind of interface for both of those
constructs just again for kind of
predictability reasons
so we talk about engagement in terms of
the percent of the organization that's
engaged versus mixed or kind of
on the fence you know maybe engaged
sometimes but not always
versus disengaged
uh so the percents are easy to see here
as a
as a bar graph and then there's always a
change score toggle that's a plus minus
the va's dots are for reference again so
if you're the director of boston or
whatever facility you can easily see
where you fall against va itself
and then for every bar graph you can the
the one layer down here is you can click
on the bar and the little
cursor kind of turns into a hand to kind
of cue you into that
you can click on the bar and see a drill
down onto
in a few different ways on that specific
construct
so for disengagement here for example we
see it by supervisory level
from most disengaged to least
by service
a lot of variance here again fake data
the little banner at the top gives that
away but
you do see you know 40 50 sometimes more
uh points of variance at the surface
level
uh work group again those small teams of
five 10 15 people
and you see the most variants here
because people who are in the same
occupation don't all have the same
supervisor
and uh so
that's why there's usually more variance
at the work group level there's a
supervisor effect basically
and then info will just have background
on that specific construct
so this is nice because we've got you
know maybe 15 20 people doing these
briefings
and some people are more or less
familiar with some of the details of the
measures so it's a great reference for
us but also for
uh our executive audience because we
leave this app up all year and there's a
lot of traffic throughout the year
people come back to it
and so you can easily remind yourself
what the details of that measure are
for engagement and for burnout we also
have hot spot and bright spot maps
so these are like those maps you saw a
minute ago but now we pull specific
groups out that have either a concerning
score in the case of a hotspot or a good
score in the case of a bright spot
so these are groups where disengagement
is at least 50 percent so you get that
quick kind of triage and
again capitalizing on the schema of the
org chart that people are already
familiar with
same thing for bright spots engagement
of 75
so in this case for example it's useful
to see the org chart display because if
you're the chief of social work you can
see you've got three groups that
that meet this threshold
if it was the reverse and you had three
groups that met the disengagement
threshold there'd be some sort of
cluster effect likely
so you'd want to know about that
so burnout is next and it's the same uh
the same kind of display for
predictability reasons
uh
here we talk about the percent of the
organization that has zero
one two or three out of three symptoms
of burnout at least once a week
so the more symptoms you have of course
the more burned out you feel
so the bar graph show the scores
the dots for reference for va overall
the drill downs by clicking on the bar
we have free sex themes here as well so
in in the survey that this data comes
from people can also leave free text
comments and we theme those and report
them out verbatim as well we bring in
the themes here just as a kind of idea
of what's top of mind for people when
they're prompted to say something about
their workplace
so
as you can probably imagine in
healthcare especially now burnout is
top of mind for a lot of folks so you
see that quantitatively and also
qualitatively in the comments
uh hotspot and brightspot maps again
and then we have two questions a lot of
bright spots here in this fake set uh we
have two comments about kova or two
questions about covid rather
extra
professional stress because of covet and
extra personal stress because of coving
and the scale is from none to extreme so
you can see the distribution there
uh and then i'll spare you the detail
again but you can click on the bar and
see the same drill downs as you've seen
so far
uh any questions before i jump to the
next section
yes there are a few other questions
coming in
from youtube and linkedin
um
one was
can you touch upon performance giving
multiple users using the app
simultaneously
so we have a
it's a 16 core
64 gig server
and we can handle
about a hundred people at the same time
that's across a few applications though
and some are
more ram heavy than this is although
this is still pretty heavy
uh there's a there are huge data sets
that go into this and we try to cut them
down and do as much pre-work as we can
but there's no way around some of it
so
we have
we do okay with 100 at that size server
you can play with the settings and
connect um how eager versus
unwilling it is to spin up a new session
for incoming users so you can have more
people piled onto the same process or
you can have more processes
it's some experimentation
there's also shiny canon uh i think
that's the the search term you want to
use to do some testing
um but that's at least our experience
thank you
um another question that was over on
slido that i see has been upvoted a few
times was was the ui all done with
bslib or did you also incorporate
javascript and css
uh it's the the base is bslib and
there's a lot of custom css yeah
not so much javascript i think the only
script i can think of offhand is what
toggles it to be full screen to remove
the browser noise at the top
so not a lot of javascript
but a lot of css yeah
thank you
and this question i think was shared in
a few different places um
but it was can you either share code
with us or give general guidance on
where to learn the click on like drill
down interface function
yeah uh the
so the the maps i'll start at the top
the maps are from
uh let me go back up here
these maps are using collapsible tree
it's like that's the package name
so there's a there's a shiny binding
that gives you the input so you can use
that to generate a modal that has the uh
the information for the thing that was
clicked on
so that's how to do it here
uh for
bar graphs
these are all done with plotly and
there's similarly there's a there's a
binding for shiny there's a click
binding that you can use to reference
the
uh for example the row number of the
data set that corresponds to the bar
that was clicked on
so it's a little finicky to set up but
once you get it it's pretty reliable
that's that's how we do it
great thank you i was trying to find the
links very quickly and share them in the
chat as well but i can also
share those with the recording i see
somebody had asked
if this session will be available later
and yes right after the session the
recording goes up at the same youtube
live link
okay one other question um
i see that
giannis asked
how could i integrate an r markdown file
which could export more than one
interactive plot at once in a shiny
application
hmm
i don't know haven't done it
best of luck though
we can
we could try and find
some other resources too or if anybody
has ideas feel free to share them in the
chat
and then one other sorry one other
question eugene asked to clarify
um
how do you serve the dashboard
is it on our studio connect or
yeah we so we have a connect instance
that's on azure and so we just get a
link for for this page and send it out
to everybody yeah
i see matthew had a question too about
uh it's anonymous
but it can be attributed to the manager
um yeah so the intent of this and this
takes a lot of
work and sort of institutional
familiarity to actually make it stick
but we've been doing this for
you know 15 years or so now so we've got
some of that the purpose of this is
purely developmental
um the only thing that's in performance
plans has to do with using the data
um not about getting a specific score or
anything like that
so yeah by mapping it on the org chart
there is
like you can see who supervises what
group
um
but
virtually no one uses it uh for that
purpose because the data wouldn't be
useful then if we did that like as soon
as you create a standard that's going to
be
mandated or you create a bar that has to
be cleared then people find ways to
clear it
even if that may not be how they
actually feel
thanks ryan good question
uh
so the next section is a different kind
of display um just a table format here
for d e and i data
the the cool thing here though is the
comparisons we do not really the the
display itself
so we've got four d e and i questions
and those are linked above but
uh we use those and also three overall
experience indicators best places to
work engagement and burnout
and for every demographic we test the
minority against the majority
and then shade where the minority is
lower than the majority
so if you see a lot of red basically it
means that in this
hypothetical organization
people who you see have red cells are
reporting more discrepant experiences on
the topics you see the red cells for
than the majority categories for their
demographic
so for disability status for example
people who said they do have a
disability uh 21 discrimination versus
11 for people who say they don't have a
disability
and there are two pages because we have
so many demographics that make too big
of a table to show it at once but
as you can imagine this is very
interesting for executives to see
and there's also change scores again
available here and for those the
comparison is every group to itself last
year rather than to its majority
and if they improve then they get green
or whatever you've changed the good
color to be
if they went down they get red
the next piece of there's three main
pieces of deni here
the next piece is about
intersectionality because of course one
demographic doesn't describe anybody
very well
so here you can pick patterns of
demographics and see how people feel
about
those same measures but who meet
multiple demographic conditions
sorted so that it's high to low
discrimination
and
of course that's the the coloring is is
a basic heat map scheme
and finally we have hot spots again here
for those four questions
uh so for each of those questions we can
pull again those groups out of the or
chart and see
uh where some concerning scores may be
we don't do bright spots here because
there's no way to know uh whether a
group is being very equitable and
inclusive and so on or whether it may
just not be a diverse group in the first
place
uh so hots so bright spots wouldn't
really work well here but
hot spots do
second to last data piece we have here
priorities and turnover intent
so priorities show what people in the
group say they most want to work on over
the next year
so we can see that prioritization
same click events as before
same thing for turnover intent which as
you can imagine if you're an executive
you want to know who's thinking of
leaving and
where you may have some staffing
shortages
and then what's pushing people away
so the reasons people who said they want
to leave gay for wanting to leave in the
first place
uh the last data piece here has to do
with just culture so if you're not
familiar with that term the idea is just
that people need to feel especially in
safety critical
applications like healthcare uh need to
feel like they can speak up and say when
something's not right
uh but also that there are standards and
they're transparent and equitable and so
on
so you want to be up here in this top
right area and you don't want to be in
this off diagonal
so this is a plotly scatter plot
the background color is of course just
going to cue you into where the
desirable range of scores for the for
these issues are
and you can change the questions to get
different views you can search and see
for example all um
all nursing groups at once if you wanted
to
and then you can also toggle between
work groups which is the default and
between occupations
because again those are similar but
specific
and finally there's a table below that
has these
these same scores
but you can also if you wanted to see
the lowest groups all at once you can
drag a
lasso
and the table updates to only show those
groups and then you can download this
table
easily to excel
uh the the tables are using the dt
package so
uh you get the
the sortability and the downloading and
so forth uh kind of by default or at
least very easily through that
through that interface
executives usually want to recognize
groups that do well
so it's easy to get additional resources
we make available here or to see a table
that's sorted automatically by
by default just to make it easy to do
that
and then finally we have just a bunch of
extra resources that people have gotten
used to seeing in va
extra reports the data store is another
app that's on connect that we made that
makes it really easy to pull specific
data at in in data set form versus in
report form
other dashboards and tools and videos
and so on
the bookmark button is great if you're
using connect because or i think shiny
apps does it also
um this will give you a custom url that
remembers all of your input selections
so if you're the director of boston
let's say and you've gotten to this
point and you've set up the page the way
you want you can hit bookmark and then
save
save a url that will
pre-load all those same selections for
you next time
so it's easy to come back and kind of
pick up where you left off
uh hotspot and bright spot downloads
just give you excel files of those
groups
and then this is just the basic uh
bootstrap uh accordion
so that's that's the app happy to talk
about it more or any any piece of it
more uh but that's what i want that's
what i had to show you
thank you so much ryan this is amazing
i see a lot of people commenting in the
chat
that are impressed with
impressed with your plots and the app in
general as well
let me jump over to slido and and see
some of the other anonymous questions
too
one question was
what did you use to create the tables in
the app was it dt
dt okay yeah dt
awesome
um another was how long did it take to
get this app up and running
um
we had a previous version of it so it's
hard to say because a lot of the back
end was
in various stages of completion i'd say
you know
a month maybe it's it's it's been a
while and it's it's hard you know you
don't track the hours you know as you go
i'd say a month probably of solid solid
work to get it where it is now
yep
awesome
um another was
if this is an annual survey how much
time or months are dedicated to the
various steps of analysis then ui design
and reporting
yeah so we the survey this year went out
in june it was open for most of june
we get the so there's a
we do most of it we don't collect the
data ourselves for a variety of reasons
there's a vendor who collects the data
for us
we get the data from them early july and
we started briefings uh august 29th
so there's a lot of analysis that goes
on data cleaning and building additional
reports that i haven't shown you and
building this and so it's a you know
maybe 45 or so business days of
development time
and
then throughout the rest of the year
the team that i'm on and me will spend
you know maybe
10 15 of our time on improving it for
next year um
filling in some of the the gaps or
taking out some of the hacks we had to
do at the last minute
that's great i see somebody just else
just asked um
i can't copy it over quick enough
but what they asked what did the process
of designing the ui look like it's so
clean but there's so much information in
there you have specific expertise weigh
in
uh trial and error uh we have we have a
few executives we partner with and kind
of bounce ideas off of
um
doesn't mean we build it exactly to
their specs because you do have your own
uh your own theories of presentation and
what's effective and what's not but
there is that feedback
the overall aesthetic is based on
microsoft's fluent design language so if
you google like microsoft fluent it'll
show you their style guide
so it's easy to well not easy but it's
possible to use css to replicate some of
that
and this matches roughly sort of the
microsoft corporatey vibe that some of
our other enterprise level applications
have
so to an executive who isn't you know
checking you know all these apps all the
time it looks familiar and seems
credible uh so that's that's the point
of the aesthetic we have here
that's awesome
a question that i had um
was how has the use of the app in these
executive briefing sessions changed the
conversation
or maybe
change some of the
the work that the team's doing
i think it drives a lot of the work the
team does and certainly changes it from
what it used to be
so you can imagine the alternative to
this would be you know a 200 slide pdf
or powerpoint
uh and at that level of detail you're
really only taking away the site scores
overall you can't focus on
where the hotspots and bright spots are
for example because there's just so much
uh so it becomes an issue of uh support
you know in specific areas for specific
topics rather than just sort of letting
the data kind of wash over you and
having a vague impression of how people
feel
uh that's that's the main difference
from the bottom up side um i mentioned a
few but they're
the the things people are able to do as
a result of these conversations are
really remarkable backlog
reductions and claims
better patient handoffs between
different care teams and facilities
others are more lighthearted
there's just so many things people do
i see jim masta i realized a similar
question too um
and it was what is the return on
investment for the va
uh it's a lot it's it's hard to quantify
as you can imagine like it's you can't
put a dollar amount easily on something
like
uh you know smoother patient handoffs or
better communication on your team
uh some of the things we quantified had
to do with
um
uh
claims reduction backlogs of you know
five ten percent which are you know at
the scale
that we have is a lot
um
savings from
uh duplicative processes across
different teams that maybe didn't know
about it before but they start talking
and see that they've both got this ready
so yeah there's not one number but it's
if there was i think it would be quite
high
great thank you
you see one other question that just
came through on slido was
do you put this shiny app behind any
sort of user authentication like octa
uh no but that sort of happens for us
because we're on
the federal cloud so to get to it you
have to be on va's network basically
you have to be in our active directory
but beyond that no it's open to anybody
in va
great thank you
um one other question
i had is if somebody's watching this
right now and
hoping to be able to create an app like
this and it's just getting started
um what would you recommend for them in
learning shiny
that's a good question i would say take
it slow be
be incremental um
if you pick you know some
you know pick your own sophisticated
application that you may have seen if
you try to do that right away
it's probably not going to work and be
frustrating
so for me i try to get everything on the
screen
and then do the ui so sort of like how
markdown breaks down the content versus
the the markup
um
i just want to get the data on the
screen and then i come back and
make a formatting pass and you revise
and iterate
uh so
you know persistence is kind of a boring
answer but that's that's my answer and
figuring out how to google things well
is a big part of it too
yeah what did this app look like in its
first stages
not good um
a lot of the data was there uh it was a
lot slower so i mentioned speed as
something that's important um
taking another run through the back end
and focusing on speed was really
important
if you have a lot of data i haven't
found anything faster than data.table
uh i think there may be a tidyverse
wrapper package for that
but if you need things to happen fast
then our data.table's the way to go um
yeah so how did it look before it was
more of a default uh bootstrappy type
look and it wasn't really it didn't fit
well on different screen sizes
wasn't mobile friendly and so this will
reorient itself if you're on
uh a mobile device you know to be to at
least display
usably well
uh so it was much more rudimentary
before
did you just hit that point where you're
like frustrated with the 200 page
powerpoint or how did you make the
switch over
uh it was frustration personally and
sort of in aggregate across our office
because we could just tell that i mean
you sort of know that you're not getting
people exactly what they need at that
level of
detail you know with that huge of a
presentation
but
getting to something that could actually
scale
for us is really important because we
have 50 people versus you know 420 000
so
we do reports in
flex dashboard for every site so
figuring out how to do that opened up
some doors
we do
single page pdfs for every work group so
30 000 pdfs
uh just figuring out how to do it at
scale was really the barrier for us we
we knew for a while we could do better
but just needed that
uh toolbox to be to
be in place for us
i want to make sure i didn't miss
anybody's questions so if i did from
earlier
please feel free to just copy and paste
it again into youtube or linkedin or
slido i think i've seen
everything over on slido but just want
to double check
ryan for for other
government or public sector employees
who are trying to make the case for
open source technologies or
being able to use r in python i know you
said finding an executive sponsor was
really helpful whether is there other
advice that you have too
yeah and this gets to someone else's
question about roi as well um
if you can get contractors to price you
out what this looks like for them to do
then the roi becomes quite clear
we've had estimates for you know
100 000 plus for every site so when you
have a few hundred sites you're talking
dozens of millions of dollars
so you know compared to i think we
we have a 350 person license connect uh
contract so
the roi there just in terms of
replacement cost is quite high if you
can show that then that's
that's one option uh if it's being done
then you're they're probably paying more
for it than it would cost to
make in-house
um
i would say make sure you go through
your organization's i.t process from the
beginning even though it's gonna be
painful and you're gonna want to
lean on that executive to get you around
certain barriers make sure you're still
checking all the boxes because when it
comes time to maintain your system or if
the you know if the maintenance
contractor changes there are all sorts
of things that can happen
and then you fall through the cracks
or maybe maybe your sponsor moves on and
then you have to get funding again so
do it
slowly but the right way i think versus
uh trying to reach for that kind of you
know skip to the front of the line
method even though it's attractive
thank you i see one question i oh it
just disappeared
one question i think i missed earlier
was um someone asked did you
have you looked at arrow or parquet
instead of data.table
i i know the term arrow i have i haven't
done any more looking into it than that
because data table's been fast enough uh
for us but
i i know there are newer alternatives
yeah
i think they're in some of the data
table benchmarks that i saw last
cool um one other follow-up question on
that example you said of like going
through the it process
very early
um
how
how did you kind of build relationships
with the i.t team
and is it like essentially managed by it
now
sort of so there's a more central
decision-making body that that
uh in sort of a more distributed
implementation body is sort of the rough
way of the land
um
you start to
you know at least get name recognition
with folks and then
uh
depending on where your organization is
positioned you may have additional
overlap with some it functions like we
have a few other things we do that put
us on it's radar
so they they knew a little bit about us
and it wasn't like we're a complete
stranger coming into them
uh and and to be fair to them also you
know at least for us i know other
agencies you know look different but
the scale of va i.t is like us coming
with this is sort of like asking
uh asking a shipyard to to build a kayak
you know it's sort of in the ballpark of
the thing they do but it's it's just
such a different scale
and it's not related directly to patient
care it's not a benefits processing
system you know so it's a little bit
outside
their immediate concern so
being understanding of their reality too
i think is important showing some
empathy
and just
being persistent really is the best
advice i can give
great thank you
one last question i have for you before
we go i know you had commented in here
who works for the va as well i was
curious do you have some sort of
like data science community or like user
group internally
i think there are a couple uh we have a
team's channel of our users
it's it's fairly decentralized as far as
i can tell
there are different offices that have
their own teams that focus on their own
functions
so there's not it's at least not that
i'm connected to there's not a large
centralized data science in va
organization
let me double check once more see if
there are any other
questions
thank you for letting us throw all these
questions at you
i don't see any others but really
appreciate you sharing the app with us
it's amazing and
and so cool to see the impact that it's
had in the organization as well
um if people do want to get
in touch with you at at some point after
is linkedin the best way to stay in
touch
yeah linkedin's okay i i don't i'm not
active and i don't check it very often
but i guess i'll get the notification if
someone messages me so that's fine
um the first page of my slides if you
have that my email is linked behind my
name
it's just
ryan.derrickson.va.gov so feel free to
reach out there too
awesome well thank you so much ryan
really appreciate it thank you all have
a great rest of the day everybody
i'll see you next week